[Musique]
l'anniversaire
g data les bougies sont applaudis gauche
charles à elle a passé la nuit dans les
clubs sado maso et puis rentré
directement la tâche
j'étais pas très happy pas
mais ce domaine une meuf de mon âge se
foutent à oilpé sans être rafistolé avec
les miches qui tombait puis la cellulite
levante comme ça et les uns ce qu'ils
font comme ça pas épilée rien du tout
mon dieu ça arrivait beaucoup de choses
non on est bien dans une société
patriarcale et sexiste cette lettre oui
j'ai essayé débordante
bah oui moi j'ai pas la classe de l'anel
que vraiment non que je trouve
formidable qui se lève qui voit là elle
est super jolie
moi je suis pas de belles comme lg pas
sa classe moi ma force c'est d'être
moche et populaire et vulgaire parce que
vulgaire c'est qu'il vient du peuple et
donc si ça gêne des jambes à posez vous
la question pour que ça vous gêne
messieurs dames ce qui est ce qui
m'inquiète c'est en fait le peu de de
tolérance qu'on a aujourd'hui à la
provocation c'est à dire que là c'est en
gros c'est la version de droite de là
quand cette culture quoi c'est on veut
ce qui les choque c'est pas tellement
que qu'une femme soit nu ce qui les
choque c'est qu'elles soient nus pour
exprimer des opinions qu'il a eu les
chocs
certaines des deux unions organisé par
l'unef serait interdite aux blancs sur
repos mélanie l'usc la présidente de
l'unef a répondu à ces accusations
des faits qu'elle reconnaît mais elle
souhaite tout de même remettre les
choses dans leur contexte
mélanie luce précise que oui les
personnes blanches ne sont pas invités à
certaines réunions sur le thème du
racisme car elles n'en sont pas victimes
mais précise toutefois que lors de ces
rassemblements aucune décision n'est
prise au nom de l'unef
il ne s'agit là que de groupe ii
rool situe à l'isi patrick sébastien je
connais bien parce qu'elle chantait sais
je sais en première partie c'est même
pas si on veut trouver du racisme on à
en trouver
alors lisez ça s'il cherchait noix de
coco moi je te donne quoique à des gens
qu'on dit que les noix de coco
correspondait aux noix des noirs et que
le l'ananas était blanc parfait ch joue
cet épisode belge entre dans le cadre
d'un phénomène appelé la cancel culture
ou culture de l'effacement venus les
états unis elle vise à boycotter des
oeuvres à évincer des personnalités
suspectées de racisme de sexisme
d'homophobie en les discréditant
publiquement la péta par exemple
l'aspect alessia pourrait me reprocher
de faire un hommage aux sardines qui
s'est quand même très cruel de les
mettre dans des boîtes sans leur tête
c'est quand même des animaux qu à qui on
enlève la tête mais où on va là faut
arrêter
aujourd'hui alors que je t'aime dalle
idées comme un cheval mort [ __ ] chaud
alors l'association explique dans un
communiqué que plusieurs internautes
l'ont alerté en voyant un candidat
arnaud tenté de pêcher une ré avec une
machette on le voit lancer la machette
sur la rai et raté sa cible ce qui a
donc suffi pour choquer certains
défenseurs des animaux qui s'indignent
d'avoir vu le même candidat piétiner une
murène quelques instants plus tard on a
adopté pendant une semaine on en était
trop fan mais en fait après ils étaient
mignons comme ça mais il allait devenir
mais ça vous le saviez des débuts waimes
je sais pas on a imaginé qu'il serait
resté tout petit alors attention pas
cela moi du coup je vais vouloir vous
demander qu'est ce qu'il en est advenu
de ce cochon clash nyon chorizo cette
indignation a surtout fait sourire les
internautes qui pour la plupart rappel
je cite que koh lanta est un jeu de
survie sur une île déserte
donc si on s'indigne des convois
donc dès qu'on les voit touchée un
poisson on n'a pas fini de s'indigner
ça c'est clair si en plus il faut se
battre pour la bernoise libéré alors à
shanghai la dernière ma mode et bien
c'est les cafés animalier vous
connaissiez les bars à chats et bien
bienvenue dans les erp en café alors
rassurez vous insérez pts ils ne sont
pas venus
v veut ni mot pardon même s'il ment de
tous je ne vous sent pas vraiment
convaincu elisabeth vous préférez peut
être à les prononcer avait dans ses
seize départements de nouvelles mesures
de freinage massive de l'épidémie
interviendront à compter de ce vendredi
soir minuit et pour quatre semaines
il est bon d'en prendre un en cas de
maux de tête
[Musique]
absolument on n'est pas des bêtes à
travailler du lundi jusqu'à 18 heures au
vendredi et pas sortir le week-end enfin
ne l'est pas on n'est pas des bêtes on
n'est pas des chiens n'est pas dans des
zones comme ça parce que le propos je
voudrais vous êtes enfin on est fou mais
non mais et puis vous vous n'êtes pas
seul terrain depuis une dizaine de jours
les israëliens on retrouve une vie
incroyablement normale grâce à une
campagne de vaccination massive et vous
aussi monsieur je vous met dans le même
sac me suis excusé moi parce qu il a
bien fallu faire de la politique parce
que toro mais oui justement lui il est
venu de la police n'aurait dû confiner
le 29 janvier
mais regardez moi c'est moi finir pour
les gens meurent les gens où elle meurt
aujourd'hui on fait quoi quand même
politique de dubaï
dallas narcissique ou telle on y est
mais non mais faites ce que vous voulez
attaquer moi c'est non mais là cela lui
a valu un jouet en politique je suis
d'abord médecin cher monsieur d'accord
voilà ce qu'en corse après midi gt5 19h
dans mon cabinet j'ai pas de leçon à
recevoir de votre part je vous parle de
ça parce que j'ai tout fait pour rester
médecin justement donc vos accusations
vous savez ce que vous en faites cher
monsieur vous voulez garder profonde et
moi parce que moi je les attaque pas
personnellement sur ce que vous faites
mal non plus j'étais d'accord le nom
vous connaissez boutines vous y pensez
que c'est un tueur
oui bien sûr c'est donc quel prix
doivent ils payer le prix qu'il doit
maintenant vous vous calmez un tout
petit peu monsieur vous m'attaquez plus
comme vous l'avez fait parce que ça ne
rime à rien et vous prêchez un ridicule
j'ai dû tout le contraire
il fallait tout simplement cher monsieur
confiné et vacciné sécurité le début et
c'est tout maintenant l'oreille vous
faites ce que vous voulez vous énerver
mais vous savez quoi je n'ai absolument
rien à faire beaucoup
le ton est celui d'une bagarre de cour
de récré mais c'est la paix du monde qui
est en jeu a besoin c'est celui qui le
dit qui l'est ce n'est pas juste et
l'expression enfantine une blague
le sens est profond et psychologique
nous voyons toujours en l'autre nos
propres caractéristiques
bouaké au jury que vous croyez que
j'aime a baissé à un niveau comme ça je
termine je terminais clair que la mienne
bonfoh
alors comment s'échapper d'une énième
visioconférence un développeur a mis au
point un zoom escape heures un outil qui
simule toutes sortes de bruits lors de
réunions en ligne de l'écho sur la voie
des pleurs de bébé du vent ou encore un
marteau piqueur autant d' excuses
imparable et cumulables pour vous
déconnecter si le télétravail devient
trop pesant